this is actually hilarious man you know
the super bowl ratings tanked right
of course but it's worse than people
realize because they didn't release the
real numbers
so i've got the story from the new york
times super bowl ratings hit a 15-year
low
it still pro outperformed everything
else yeah sure
but let's look i got to go through this
because the numbers are hilarious
they say sunday's super bowl was watched
by just 91.6 million people on cbs
the lowest number of viewers for the
game on traditional broadcast television
since 2006.
a total of 96.4 million watched on uh
watched
when other platforms like the cbs
all-access streaming service
and mobile phone apps were counted the
lowest number of total viewers since
2007.
do you know what they're not saying this
year for the first
time they're including out of home
viewership
they're trying to make it seem like the
numbers are the same they're not
when they they say at its peak in 2015
114 million people watched
that was people at their in their homes
watching tv
now what they're saying is including
other people who watched outside of the
home so what are the real numbers
because the real numbers could be
substantially lower
you know what i see with this when i see
the super bowl ratings tank
nba ratings tanked oh ratings for sports
have been going down
i think the american cultural
you know empire is to completely shatter
into a million pieces
music is no one listens to the same
music anymore and i think it really is
the internet
ultimately i think this is going to lead
to hypertribalism it's contributing to
the hyperpolarization
there's no unified american culture
anymore
so what you end up getting alongside
things like this people don't agree on
what
is or isn't so a good example of what
was wrong with the super bowl
they they had a couple commercials that
mocked conservatives 74 million trump
voters got made fun of
by super bowl ads because they the these
marketing companies probably don't know
what to do
who do we pander to well how about
pandering to neither because yeah the
divide is too big
so a lot of people just won't watch
super bowl conservatives especially i'm
not going to watch it
especially now after being made fun of
so the more they do this
the more they lose power and the more
conservative institutions and
infrastructure will start being built
and then what happens now that we have
you know the daily wire doing their own
movies
what happens in five years when you have
two completely parallel economies
where neither side talks to each other
but they they
they fight for the same government
somebody's going to throw a punch
somebody's going to pull out a cane in
congress like back in you know 18. i
would love that i'd love it to go third
world man don't you like watching like
thailand where they just jump up and
it's battle royal
i was in thailand doing uh in 2014
and i got to stand in one of those
vehicles with blood stains all over it
because someone chucked a grenade into
it
you don't want to live that way man i
mean i don't want kids i don't want
chaos
obviously and i think that's why a lot
things haven't popped off worse than
they could because everyone knows we
have a good hair
and they don't want to mess it up that
not not yet though
yeah that's what i'm saying look at the
idea of the dueling pillow companies
people don't care about the usefulness
of a product anymore because
americans are fat and happy there's
nowhere else to go
i mean theoretically we need i i
shouldn't say theoretically
literally what we need what we need is a
unified culture with
goals you don't have that the goal of
the left and the right now becomes
destroying the
other and the other is their their their
imagined enemy you make me think of like
bread and circus because you were saying
how like
sports have failed almost in their in
their attempt to assuage the the
community because we got the internet
if the romans had the internet we would
never they would never would have
created that giant empire because you
would have gallic
propaganda versus jedi sort of making
youtube videos you would have hannibal
telling everybody
what what how oppressive the romans were
in rome they'd be like oh we'll screw
this
so that's where we're at now and
everything's fracturing and shattering
and decentralizing
but think about it but in in in the
roman empire communication can only
travel so fast
and when you control the roads and the
military
you control the information so then
people only learn what you allow them to
learn
and that stops dissent what are they
doing now with everything
censorship mass censorship control of
information
because the system is breaking down they
started losing control a long time ago
super bowl ratings are our proof of it
nba ratings before this
they tried putting black lives matter on
the courts kick out the fans nobody
wanted to watch it yep
but see i i i know this might be crazy i
think people are coming together
i do i think what you see on the on
social media
and on television is a war
because that's what they want you to
believe that there's a war going on but
when you actually take a look at it how
many latinos voted for trump
black conservatives bigger i mean that's
the most punk rock stuff i've ever seen
black conservatives
you know more than ever and then you had
like you know i mean like conservatives
are pretty laid-back people today what
conservative is
compared to when i started stand-up
which was like super religious
now it's just like hey man don't take my
guns i don't want to get taxed
and let me live my life i feel like
people are coming together more
off the mainstream stuff and when you
were bringing up about
this uh satellite i mean about the super
bowl and the numbers
that's the same thing they do with uh
with the news they
count airports airports hotels
right six million people watched in an
airport oh in a hotel like because
there's thirty thousand people going
through the airport they say there's
also two thousand
wow they've ended that cnn's ended the
airport network the cultural control is
shattering so i i look at what's going
on with like the democratic
establishment
i look at what's going on with joe biden
and i'll tell you this joe biden may
have won because
people hated trump but this is the
establishment's last leg
i mean come on man the super bowl is is
falling
the worst numbers in in 13 years is it
going to get better i really doubt it
you got to understand the super bowl
should have attracted more viewership
because streaming is ubiquitous
people can watch more than ever and they
didn't do it and you know i'll tell you
this
that number is up by one because we had
the tv on in the background while we
were playing magic the gathering
we didn't care about the super bowl it
was just on tv and we ignored it i think
for one way for
sports to save themselves is if they
integrate the rest of the world
and start having teams from other
countries play no no that's not the
issue the issue is what entertains us is
fracturing right
so skateboarding for instance i've never
been big into mainstream sports i've
always been big into skateboarding
skateboarding is a counter culture it's
always been
skateboarders do you know they go to to
buildings
and then actually cause damage to
property a lot of skateboarders don't
want to admit it and they'll be like no
no it's not that bad
come on when you wax up that that you
know ledge in front of the store the
planter
and then it turns black and gray and
it's permanently discolored
yeah people don't like that stuff it was
counter culture there's videos all over
instagram of people fighting with
security guards i hate it i can't stand
it
don't fight you you don't you blow up
the spot what you do is security guard
comes out you say one more try says no
you leave
then you wait you come back later or you
just don't come back and go and skate
somewhere where you're not gonna you
know bring too much heat or get somebody
hurt
but this has always been counterculture
mainstream sports has always been
acceptable
and what's happening now is from music
to movies to video games
there's so much the options are endless
that people aren't turning on one
network anymore to watch one game
to become relatable they're trying to
find communities
close to them so one of the things i
think is happening with the lockdowns is
a desperate attempt to get everyone to
watch the same news to watch the same
stories
and to think the same thing because they
want everyone to be unified
under the same culture at the very least
but right now facts
don't make sense the democrats you know
they're coming out saying donald trump
incited a riot
and i talked to my friends and they're
like we know he did look what he said
and i'm like that video's fake
the democrats they put this video up on
impeachment and they edited out what
trump said
they made they fabricated fake tweets
during an impeachment trial unbelievable
the democrats
fabricated fake tweets to accuse the
date was wrong on one of them
and they added a verified badge to some
random account to make it seem
like a public figure was saying certain
things fake and then trump's defense
called it out the point is
there are people who believe entirely
fake things on one side
there are people who believe entirely
fake things on the other side and there
are
a lot of people probably the people who
watch shows like this who are mostly
kind of on one side but understand where
the lies are coming from
and understand what is really going on
what i often say is
the fringe faction of conspiracy
theorists on the right
has no institutional power and is often
rejected by mainstream conservatives the
q stuff
then you look at the mainstream left and
russiagate is mainstream
the the fringe lunacy fake news on the
left is the
is the is the paramount of their of
their tribe and their culture
on the right it's not regardless of
whether or not you want to rag on them
you can call me bias that's fine
the fact is there is no bridge there's
no in-between anymore
i i there there's that time magazine
article about how the shadow campaign
and the cabal you saw that one
yeah i have my theory i said it to a
friend and they said
this proves the democrats were helping
save the election
and protecting us from trump's voter
fraud and i'm like how did you read that
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter i
know i'm not going to convince these
people
because they live in a different
universe there's no middle anymore
i am not a staunch conservative i read
that and they say conspiracy conspiracy
is negative
and people will just want to defend
their tribe so
with with the super bowl with the nba
with these tv shows the ratings are
dropping because people
can choose infinitely and communities
are no longer unified
so now we're going to see hyper
tribalization because of this we're
starting to see
people who are more likely to watch the
super bowl and be democrat go to interst
they go to the cities and the people in
the cities who are more likely to just
want to be independent left alone move
out out into rural areas kind of like
what we did and it's making the cities
bluer
and the rural areas redder and it's
dividing everybody based on culture
and geographic location and history
tells us exactly what that leads
to yeah i mean i i
i have a couple of opinions on that one
is that i i
do you think they want us unified under
i think they want us all fighting with
each other
so we can't be unified no no they want
us fighting over wedge issues but
unified over a set of facts
they want us to agree that say trump is
bad
but argue about say abortion and
taxation
but you know in a way it's also not
working i still find it perplexing that
in august of last year
tv shows like tucker carlson were
dominating nba
prime time games and he was getting way
more viewers than professional sports
um and that's tucker carlson fox news of
all people if you
if you would have asked me back in the
day when tucker carlson was still
wearing a bow tie if this would happen i
wouldn't ever believe you
i would think you would be crazy but now
he's this kind of symbol of
anti-establishment they're trying to
take him down
and also we have to point out as i
talked about i think in yesterday's show
or two shows ago
that apps like signo and telegram are
becoming the most popular apps in the
world
and they are far surpassing the number
of downloads then facebook
and twitter then youtube which shows you
that the people are moving towards
communication forms that are free
that are decentralized and again there's
even some questions about that
specifically with telegram specifically
even with signal but but that's what
they usually represent
and moving to a form where they can't be
canceled and then they could say
whatever they want
without being blocked so we also look at
that you know it's just like
maybe people are tired of worshiping
people maybe like
now because like this show and your
ability could you've done this 20 years
ago
there was no thing set up like this so
that's why they're banning everybody
they're trying to bring it all back
under one roof and they can't do i mean
it's out
are the cats out of the bag and like you
know what's you know what's important
authenticity that is the collateral of
today
and they can't because once you put a
suit
in between the the creator and the
consumer
and you have to go through this filter
that changes everything
what authenticity is what people want
and when you look at something like
i mean like the nba they they they their
uh
salaries just keep going up but nobody's
watching it why is this
why is this it could be money from china
now you got problems you got
you got marxist cuban wanting not to
play
not london i played the national not
listening man i watch
i go to these events i'm like why are we
playing this and then you start to
really like i went to
the world series the dodgers when they
lost to um the cheating
houston astros right and i was on
shrooms right at the world series
and i was watching it and i'm just like
man this is just
a giant military propaganda
like event and it's and that's what the
that's what
the uh the the national anthem is so i i
i'm not really too concerned
but we all know that mark cuban wants
those chinese dollars well he he wanted
to get rid of the national anthem
yeah i think i i look you can call i
don't think it's fair to say the
national anthem is a big propaganda
event i don't know no no i'm saying
well i i i don't i don't know why we
play it before the event cultural unity
so it's similar to what a lot of what
they want now the problem is
it's one thing when we as a country say
that we're here for each other it's a
community
and we have to defend our shared values
so we sing the national anthem and the
history of the national anthem is
actually pretty amazing
i i think america is fantastic i've been
around the world and i've seen some
horrifying places
now i think the pledge of allegiance is
kind of creepy gotta be completely
honest
like pledging allegiance never never
been a big fan of pledging allegiance
america was built on defying the crown
but i understand the national anthem i
understand that big sporting events we
all come together
and what's here's what i see with these
sporting events when people can sit down
and argue over things that are trivial
to give an outlet to their anger and
their frustrations that's not
necessarily a bad thing
we can talk about bread and circuses and
it can be distracting that's a bad thing
we want people to have entertainment an
outlet a release
and something to look forward to and we
want people to be unified
in this country so i can respect that
certain idea the problem is the unity
they're trying to bring about is unity
with china
under this chinese system like luke was
saying earlier that's why
mark cuban doesn't want the national
anthem he wants to sell the nba
in china yeah that's why the nba didn't
want us supporting hong kong
yep so if you want to say hey i think we
should they're going to do the national
anthem
yeah but but the problem is you can see
the erosion in the system look
we are not a one world government this
this world is fractured
by different ideologies and different
countries and the question you need to
ask yourself is
would you rather live life like an
american or would you rather live
life like someone from china in china
they weld your doors shut when you get
sick and you die in your apartment
they take people to the police
departments and shackle them to chairs
and then torture them for insulting
police
they have concentration camps the us is
not a saint
this country has done bad things but i
tell you this right now we are
so tolerant that we're actually having
these
overly tolerant people destroy
everything we have given
so much to those perceived to be victims
and weak it's hurting us
this we need to fix we need a decent
balance but i tell you this
in 50 years and 100 years what kind of
future do you want
a future under an american constitution
that has been strengthened guaranteeing
your rights
to live to pursue happiness or a chinese
system
where everything is given up for the
state just like the fascists wanted
so when i when i hear they want to sing
the national anthem the national anthem
to me represents
the constitution which is which they
which many of these establishment elites
want to destroy
and especially our enemies if we are
fractured and we don't come together as
a community who shares these values
we will be destroyed there was a time
where they didn't make it mandatory now
it's mandatory and
that and i'm fine with that position i
just i go why are we listening this
before a pro wrestling event i think
it's a
bad song relatively it's just kind of a
crappy song like i love the song
i don't know why yeah and then
it's like what is that batman it's just
some chunky
bland melody that goes up and down
talking in like 1700s language it's like
dude
nationalism is only bad in america
everywhere else i mean listen when conor
mcgregor
or tyson fury goes and fights somewhere
they come in droves
and they sing their national anthem with
pride listen
i'm a nationalist when it comes to
sporting events
when it comes to business i don't think
american lives are more important than
iraqi likes i'm a human being and i
think people have the right
to raise their family feed their family
take care of their family and live their
life
i don't like when we're going over there
and bombing brown people
and we're acting like we're doing it to
stop terrorism when it's all about
making bankers rich okay
but the notion of not being proud to be
an american
is the most ridiculous thing i've ever
heard of
because everywhere else has huge pride
in their country when american fighters
go to fight brazilians
american fighters get booed down bad
doesn't matter who the brazilian fighter
is
brazilians always support brazilians i
get my problem is when we get like
americans that are like i guess the term
will be scum junkies that like don't do
anything or contribute to society and
say i
am great because i was born here like
you're great because of your merit if
you do good
you're great if you don't you suck but i
don't think that's a real thing for you
most people that are like i have the
power because i'm an american
even though i'm lazy i mean i grew up
with them
but they're so listen man it's okay to
be like i'm proud to be an american like
i'm from cortland new york okay
607 has the highest rate of welfare
and incest in the whole entire state and
i have a tattoo of it on my leg
i love being from there there's a lot of
junkiness there
but those that's my tribe man and like
there's nothing wrong with that and
sometimes that's all people have
tribalism based on these shared values
of freedom and individual liberty and
things that we cherish
i think is fantastic tribalism is
fraction this country because one
faction despises the constitution
and these shared values of american
culture they hate america
i think it's funny because you know it's
the it's the old trope of like kennedy
and you know the liberals hate america
and i'm like
well i don't think the liberals do i
think the far left does yes
and i think the establishment democrats
just don't
care so long as they can line their
pockets with gold that's the problem
yeah
and don't get me wrong i'm sorry i'm
sorry the republicans too if you're
international
and nationalism is their enemy
especially with you know
eastern european countries like hungary
and poland i mean i'm polish
and i'm very proud of my heritage my
history my family my bloodline
no one else could say that they fought
off the russians and the communists
and the nazis and the germans at the
same time and then still didn't give a
damn about it my family did it wasn't me
i don't want to take credit for but at
the same time
that history that feeling that that that
understanding of how bad it could get is
passed down from family member to family
member
and it's it's a miracle that poland
still exists it still does and because
of that we are eternally proud of our
country
but that's why there's such a threat
against individuals because
multinational corporations can't easily
come in and ruin and take over
everything like they want to
when you have a strong family when you
have this identity of a group of
individuals
and this is why we're seeing eastern
european countries not be taken over
just like
france germany uh the united kingdom and
other countries that are inf
infiltrated by the powers that be and
special interests that benefit off of
human suffering
so so there's there's another story i
want to pull up and this
is this is why america is is great the
way it's set up can i make a
clarification before we do that
there's a difference between patriotism
and constitutionalism like if you're an
american
but you don't support the constitution i
don't support
that type of americanism and i don't
like that kind of patriotism
because you can still be an american and
piss all over the constitution but
you don't even have to be an american to
support the u.s constitution and that's
i think more patriotic to our country
so that's where my my belief and my love
for nationalism breaks down
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time